Council of Frees, that is old news.
Today, we have a legendary creature that
can copy itself like you've never seen
before in the format of EDH. And with an
end game plan that is just peak. I I
cannot wait to pull that off, and you
will see why. Hello, everyone. This is
Jin with Next Level Commander, and today
we have another legend from the mystery
packs. You know the feeling when you see
a legendary creature, and you just know
you kind of want to build it without
even seeing what the rest of the deck
looks like, but then you dig a little
deeper and the excitement dies down
pretty quickly. We had that with Gendor,
and today we have Ugu, the Omni Plasm.
It's one of those super pushed legendary
creatures for an obscure tribe. Yeah,
this ability is really powerful, but
then you look at the tribe itself, and
you realize why it's so pushed. I looked
through all the Oozes, but
unfortunately, there just isn't that
much synergy with what Ugu is trying to
do here. I mean, it's still pretty
strong probably cuz you're you have
board wipe prevention, you have a lot of
sacrifice synergies. Sure, put in all
the Oozes, and you probably have a
decent bracket two low bracket two high
bracket one deck. That's fine. But, this
card right here has potential to do so
much more. Actually, just a few weeks
ago, I was looking into making a video
about Council of Frees, and my friend DK
even built the deck. It's pretty sweet.
You could you clone your commander, you
go into combat, you double, and then you
quadruple, you go exponential. That's
pretty sweet. But, Ugu here is going to
blow that out of the water. Yes, today
we are building all around Ugu. No
Oozes. Yeah, we don't have any Oozes in
the deck. The entire plan is copying Ugu
with just one action, we can turn one
Ugu into three, and after that, nine.
And what is that game action I speak of?
Clones. Yes, by cloning our commander,
the legend rule becomes our second ally.
So, all you have to do is just drop
clones onto the board and watch the
exponential growth. Three, nine, 27, 81.
And to speed things up, I'm tossing in
my favorite commander centric package.
You know it. It's my music,
the Undying [music] Package. So, here's
how it works. With Ugu on the field, you
target it with an Undying Malice. Yeah,
you have to do this first because
there's no window to respond when the
legend rule kicks in. Then you [music]
cast a clone to copy Ugu and you choose
to place the original Ugu into the
graveyard and it's going to come back.
Now, before the [music] return trigger
happens, you can put another, for
example, Fanged Death onto the clone so
that when Ugu comes back, the clone goes
into the graveyard and will come back
again. And after this, you can decide
which one to send into the graveyard.
Doesn't matter too much. Usually, I keep
Ugu on the field, but there are times
when, in the right scenario, you would
send Ugu to the mental. But more
importantly, quick maths. After all of
that, how many Ugus do I have on the
battlefield? Just to make it fair, I'm
also doing mental math and my answer
comes out to be 27.
I'm sure if I'm wrong, someone will let
me know, but yeah, that's nuts. And if
you see my earlier videos, you will know
building a deck around this engine gives
us so much potential for all kinds of
synergy. We have tokens, we have tribal,
we have clones. We can do aristocrats
with things dying and coming back all
the time. But before we get ahead of
ourselves, start with the core of the
deck, the clones. We have 18 of them and
we're not being picky here. There are
two criteria. The first one is it has to
be a creature, like a physical creature,
and the second criteria is that it must
be able to copy all creatures, not just
your creatures. Now, this is a bit
restrictive, but you will see why later
on. Because of our restrictions, our
choices are kind of limited. I mean,
even the OG clone is here and a lot of
the format I once come with some
utility, like Gigantoclasm can sack
itself. Vizier of Many Faces, for
example, can be used again, but not
really in the way we want. So, yeah,
cool stuff, not really worth mentioning
most of these, but there are a few
standout ones, like Pirate It Copy,
because every token we make has the same
name, Ugu, so they all trigger when they
hit. So, this is basically a clone
staple onto a Coastal Piracy and that's
really strong. And another one is
Omniclone because with this, we can copy
an opponent's creature, except it's
still an ooze, so when it dies, it
becomes two of whatever we copied. Now,
this is a bit of a spoiler cuz our end
game plan is basically this except on a
far larger scale. So, that's our clone
package with 18 of them and next up the
undying package. We're starting with the
best ones which are the reanimation
effects, the ones that can bring cards
from graveyard, but if there's a budget
restriction, you can easily replace
these with any undying effects. There's
like 10 more I haven't used. This is the
only deck I've ever played Dread Return
in cuz usually the flashback cost is
pretty hefty sacrificing three
creatures, but in this deck by sacking
three Ugu's to cast this, we can easily
make 10 more. So, undying effects we
have 13 cards. We can still carry out
our game plan with just clones, but
these make our game so much more
explosive. Okay, now we have our core
engine. It's time to reap our benefits
to enjoy the synergies. First, card
draw. Draw equal to the number of Ugu's.
The only limit here is deck size. And
removals. Remove anything and everything
that is not named Ugu. Also, mass
reanimation. Now, here be careful you're
not naming Uzi's, you're naming
shapeshifters because that's what these
are. And to make sure our deck runs
smoothly, we have some generic utility.
We've got the ramp spells, pretty
generic choices for the most part except
for a few like Harvest Season. This one
is a dead card sometimes, but when it
happens, it's all worth it. And also,
mutable explorer cuz this is an Uzi, so
I can sacrifice it and depending on the
board, I can get two copies or 18 copies
of it. And also, Arcane Signet charm
because sac outlet is kind of important
in this deck and we don't need a mass
sac outlet, we just need a land like
High Market and the charm will help us
get that. Speaking of sac outlets, we do
have Ashnod's Altar and Phyrexian Altar.
They're not actually here for the mass
sacking like in most decks, they're here
to make mana cuz oftentimes we have a
massive board and if we can turn that
into mana, we can turn 17 creatures into
47 for example. Oh, and that reminds me,
if you happen to have an Earthcraft,
that goes pretty well here. And for just
a little more card draw, we have
Yawgmoth, we have Skullclamp, and Black
Market Connections. Yeah, this one just
goes into every deck I build now.
There's so much synergy. And normally in
a deck that is so dependent on the
commander, I have a lot of protection
spells. But what's nice here is that
these undying effects also double as
protection as long as we combine them
with a sac outlet. Yeah, I just love
building decks like this where
everything is versatile, but also
interconnected. And finally, just a
piece of random utility, Word of
Invention because our deck can convoke
so well and we have a sweet package of
artifacts that we can get at instant
speed. So, that leaves us with just a
few more slots and and I was thinking,
you know, we can add in some oozes for
the late game. They can be finishers. At
first, I was thinking, but why not
putting some oozes, right? Say Ave, Ave
can make a huge army if we sacrifice it
with the right board. And also,
something like Biowaste Blob. If we play
this, sacrifice it, our oozes will
become 9/9s, 10/10s, I don't know. So,
these seem decent. I even thought about
something like Necrotic Ooze. That has a
lot of possibilities, but then but then,
something else came up. I don't know
how, but it took me a few games with
this deck to even realize this. There is
an epic end game built in already. And
that is with clones. It turns out when
you clone Ugu and you choose to
sacrifice the clone, you create X tokens
and those tokens are actually clones.
You can copy anything that is on the
board except you get 10 of them. 10
Grave Titans, 10 Avenger Zendikars, 10
Giselas cuz remember they're not
legendary or even just 10 Solemn
Simulacrums. I'll take that. And this
gives us this magical Christmas land,
this end game that I can look forward to
every every time I play Ugu. Do keep in
mind I haven't tested this deck yet, but
on paper, this is sweet. This This is a
blast to play. And for lands, we're
starting with sac outlets. We don't even
need the best ones. We're playing, for
example, Hostile Hostile and even
Myriad. They're not the most efficient,
but sometimes we just need that one sac
outlet. And after that is an interesting
one, Mutavault. That's kind of an
unconventional ramp piece in this deck
cuz with Akroma, on the field, we can
just animate it, sacrifice it as an
ooze, and it can create for us anywhere
between two to 200 Mutavault tokens. I'm
also going to play these two planes
because Station 12 is pretty easy in
this deck, and also the ability
synergize well. And then there's three
Tree City for Ooze and Nykthos cuz
remember all of these are Ugu tokens.
They have mana cost. And a few MDFCs,
and the rest of our lands are dedicated
to mana fixing. And that's the deck.
I've got a few lists prepared for this
set, but this is the first one I'm
building. I'm actually so excited to
play this. This deck is not explosive in
the sense that it goes off early. It
takes a few turns to set up, but once
you do it's going to go exponential.
You're going to go from no board to
lethal within a turn or two.
It is not the most resilient because a
lot of the card draw relies on our
engine working. So, there will be times
when you have nothing and you draw into
one of these cards. But, the point of
decks like this is we do have enough
redundancy so that even if we are
stopped once or twice, eventually we get
to carry out our game plan. The deck is
fairly easy to play, I'd say. You need
to figure out some of the triggers,
learn the sequencing, but aside from
that is fairly simple. Now, the list I
made is fairly expensive, but I do
believe this can be built on a budget.
Most of the really expensive cards are
not necessary. Like, we don't need these
altars, we don't need Nykthos.
We definitely don't need Earthcraft.
It's nice to have, but
it's fine. We just need the clones and
the undying effects. That's what we
That's the core of the deck, right? And
for power level, we are I didn't include
any game changers, but I think this deck
should be somewhere in bracket three.
Yeah, I think it might be a bit too
explosive for bracket two. And that's
all for today. Thanks for watching the
video. Once again, I'm sponsored by
Kakapopo TCG. They have some sweet
sleeves, deck boxes, dice, all kinds of
accessories. Check out their site and
use my code levels all caps for a
discount.
I'll see you in the next video.